oussama 17 ans et raf 12 ans ils ont
vécu la guerre en syrie puis la misère
dans un camp de réfugiés en jordanie
installé depuis 2016 dans son petit
appartement d'annecy qu'avec leurs
parents ils sont enfin heureux parce que
vous parliez français avant d'arriver
000 c'était un petit peu difficile les
premiers mois mais on s'est habitué à
parler avec les gens aller au
supermarché
comment comment je vais acheter des
trucs je dois parler français et ça
c'est pour mon avenir c'est parfait
j'essaie leur père souleymane ne parle
pas assez français pour accorder une
entrevue mais sa fierté pour ses enfants
sautent aux yeux
la fierté aussi d'avoir pu leur offrir
une nouvelle vie loin de la syrie après
dix ans de conflit le pays est en ruine
la moitié des infrastructures publiques
sont détruites et 80% de la population a
besoin d'eau potable de nourriture ou
d'un toit les familles là-bas sont tous
des primes et les enfants tous des prix
mais on vit pas tu ne vais pas notre
enfance donc je suis venu ici écoles en
france
amis famille tout j'ai tout ici qu'est
ce que tu aimes le plus ici les gens
font ils sont vraiment gentils ils sont
patients avec nous raf a vécu l'enfer
elle a été capturés par des soldats de
bachar al assad en fuyant avec sa mère
je suis rentré en prison avec ma mère
pour un an et demi c'était très des
faits s'est elle jamais frappé ma mère
devant moi ils m'ont brûlé le pied les
petits enfants genre qui meurent des
femmes qui sont saines qui meurent aussi
la guerre a tué près de 400000 syrien en
dix ans et six millions et demi de
personnes sont devenus des réfugiés raph
et sa mère ou de la chance un échange de
prisonniers a conduit à leur libération
et elles ont pu aller rejoindre houssame
souleymane en jour ben je pourrais peut
appeler ça de la série choix appeler ça
de la guerre pour faire cesser la boxe a
tous commencé
qu'est ce que j'aime pas ce que nous on
est en train de se chicaner entre nous
genre les séries 1 contre les syriens
que ça c'est difficile d'entendre ça
justin trudeau avait promis d'accueillir
25 mille réfugiés syriens en 2015
et selon immigration canada ils ont
finalement été 39000 comme raf et
houssam arrivée au pays au cours de
l'année qui a suivi
environ 5000 d'entre eux se sont
installés dans le grand montréal
d'autres comme noir et firas sont
arrivés plus tard après avoir été
parrainée par un proche
aujourd'hui ils travaillent tous les
deux et habite à saint bruno sur la rive
sud
quand nous sommes arrivés ils ont dit
bienvenue chez vous c'était parfait pour
nous la vie au canada c'est comme une
rêve c'est très calme ça nous donne la
paix j'ai commencé à mettre des tableaux
sur les murs parce que c'est la première
fois que j'ai je sens que je suis chez
moi
firas nous raconte mauvais souvenir
l'événement de trop qui les a poussés à
quitter la syrie et à 12 soldats qui
sont qui m'attaquent dans mon bureau
parce que parce qu'ils pensent que je
fais des des reportages et envoyait à al
jazeera
j'étais presque capturé et torturé mais
je sais pas il m'a ils m'ont laissé leur
nièce leur envoyer quelques photos de
guerre prise à damas et à homs en syrie
dit elle rares sont ceux qui osent en
prendre le régime du dictateur bachar al
assad a réussi à reprendre 70% du
territoire avec l'appui des russes le
conflit est devenu géopolitique des
millions de syriens
firas ne font qu'attendre la mort tout
est démoli d'abord les bâtiments les
économies même les gens sont démolis
dedans si tu veux la vérité
non pour moi c'est pas papa d'espoir
parce que rien n'a changé
la russie veut la série l'agreg vu la
série
errant vu la série tellement vu la série
et nous c'est loupé bassin missak lui a
décidé de parrainer une vingtaine de
membres de sa famille qu'on voit ici
photographié à montréal électricien son
compte est bien établie depuis 2003 il a
voulu les sauver de ce conflit dont
personne ne voit la fin j'ai réussi à
faire venir tout le monde tout le monde
voulait partir parce que c'était
insupportable la situation là bas
et puis là je me sens beaucoup mieux
avec avoir un fait mis toutes mes frères
et moi
il espère encore faire venir la famille
de son dernier frère encore là bas en
attendant il lui envoie de l'argent sans
aide c'est impossible de vivre tu peux
pas bien de manger tu peux pas tu veux
pas se chauffer selon lui les sanctions
internationales contre la syrie doivent
cesser c'est pas le régime disent au
fort de ces sanctions là c'est c'est le
peuple qui souffre
il n'y a pas un vrai décisions mondiales
pour cette guerre là pour sauver les uns
le canada et les autres pays doit mettre
beaucoup de pression sur cette régime
pour arrêter la guerre d appel pour
sauver ce qui reste de cette scierie
qu'ils aiment encore mais avec le coeur
en cri ici dans ce pays qui leur a à
faire un nouveau départ j'avais dans un
set mauvais souvenir et la mettre dans
la poubelle fois là moi je suis
canadienne
maintenant je fais canada c'est bon jovi
il faut avancer je peux pas rester
là-bas il faut avancer
[Musique]